Scott Disick and Sofia Ricci head to  Aspen to celebrate New Year's I guess  I'll try anything the Lord and his lady  took to Instagram on Friday to share it  these bundled up jet-setting pics as  they were headed out of town to ring in  the New Year  Sofia revealed she's quote ready for  2018 in her caption while Scott shared  he's already on a whole New Year vibe  after they landed in Aspen Colorado the  pair was spotted all smiles and having a  blast in the snow I'm just not happy  with anybody the 34 year old reality  star sure seems to have changed his tune  when it comes to his dating life Sophia  and Scott are inseparable spending  plenty of time together and sharing  their adventures of traveling the globe  to Instagram the 19 year old model even  used the l word when referring to Disick  on her Instagram story on Friday writing  love you kid  affirm that  [Music]